[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis
weltweite gibt es eine motiv torte und
zwar wird die tochter von männer
großcousine ok hört sich jetzt echt mega
krass entfernt an
aber hallo das ist die enkeltochter
meines cousins wird ein jahr alt und zu
diesem anlass habe ich eine mini maus
geburtstagstorte in form einer 1 gemacht
ich weiß es ganz genau was in den
kommentaren stellten
du machst immer trocken die sieben
mädchen aus sie sind ja in unserer
familie sind einfach viele mädchen ich
packe immer nur für die färbung im
freundeskreis muss ich ganz ganz ehrlich
es ist niemals überschuss ist eigentlich
gar nicht wirklich freuen und disco rian
gewarnt eine rein gegangen waren 99
jüngster und drei mädels so ja und jetzt
hat sich geändert aber demnächst kommt
auch noch einen jungen torte versprengt
verspreche ich und ich hab mir jetzt oft
gedacht ich hab jetzt heute die zahl
eins ist neben wird als startschuss denn
ich finde also viele haben mich schon
gefragt wie macht man den zahlen torten
da dachte ich menschlich zeigt dass
jetzt einfach mal ich zeige euch wie ihr
die backform werden müsst wie man zum
beispiel diese 1 konstruiert aus nur
einer backform ich habe den eckigen back
rahmen genommen und dann machen wir
einfach die zahlenfolge von 1 bis 0
sozusagen und dann immer ein anderes
thema das heißt ihr könnt euch jetzt
themen wünschen ich weiß harry potter
ist mir dabei aber dazu gibt es eine
eigene motiv torte das heißt da kann man
dann auch ganz viele verschiedene themen
wählen formel 1 zum beispiel feuerwehr
und so weiter bis heute starten wir mit
der einst ich habe das ganze auch muss
ich echt sagen an einem tag gebacken
bekommen
ich hab nur gestern die böden
vorgebacken und die frucht einlage
gemacht unter dieser mini maus schicht
steckt nämlich ein richtig leckere
lockerer kuchenteig eine erdbeer frucht
einlage und eine erdbeer buttercreme die
apotheke ist wirklich total live total
lecker und die etwa frucht einlage das
sind wirklich nur 100 prozent erdbeeren
ohne zuckerzusatz daher ist dort jetzt
auch nicht mega südstadt mit direct ich
fange an und zeigt euch wie ich den teig
hergestellt hat heute bereite ich zuerst
einmal den kuchen boden zu da hab ich
mir jetzt denn rohöl tag ausgesucht und
zeigt euch mal die zutaten für den teig
brauche ich sechs eier 300 gramm zucker
etwas salz eine
behandelte zitrone vanille extrakt
jeweils 300 milliliter öl und butter
milch 450 gramm mehl ein päckchen
backpulver und 200 gramm mandeln die
habe ich bereits gemacht
jetzt gebe ich zuerst einmal die eier in
einer schüssel
da nehme ich jetzt die kenwood diesen
ein bisschen größer
das wird auch eine menge teig aber passt
oder kitchenaid dann zucker dazu extrakt
und jetzt wird die masse wie etwa 56
minuten klinisch verrührt die eier
zucker muss es jetzt schön cremig jetzt
habe ich hier die zitrone da reibe ich
es die schale ab darum geht es mir dazu
und kann jetzt auch die buttermilch und
das öl zu finden
[Musik]
ohne verkleckern verhöre ich jetzt mehl
backpulver und dann kommen die zutaten
jetzt hier oben noch mit rein und werden
nur noch ganz klein gerät und wer möchte
kann an dieser stelle zum beispiel auch
back fester shops mit rein geben die
passen geschmacklich nämlich auch sehr
gut
[Musik]
und jetzt finde ich den teig in meiner
buck vom 1
dann nehme ich jetzt einen bug rahmen
habe den auf 26 x 26 cm eingerichtet
und so kommt der teig jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 160 grad ober
unterhitze etwa 35 bis 40 oder auch 45
minuten und dann nehme ich ihn raus
länger fertig ist der kuchenteig dürfte
jetzt über nacht abkühlen heute werde
ich die torte zusammensetzen und auch
dekorieren
das erste was ich heute zubereite ist
die dekoration ich habe es hier etwas
modellieren schokolade in rosa und habt
jetzt bereits zwei geknetet und mit
etwas pink eingefärbt und die werde
jetzt auf etwas becker stärke dünn
ausrollen und daraus eine schleife
formen
[Musik]
das habe ich ein langes stück ausgerollt
und jetzt wird's zurechtgeschnitten
dafür nehme ich jetzt ein bisschen glück
könnte aber auch ein normales messer
benutzen
ich schneide ich jetzt aus einem stück
weg und je nachdem wie groß die schleife
sein so schneidet ihr selbst so ich
probiere jetzt vorher einmal aus kann
ich das ganze umdrehen und zur mitte
klappen und markiere jetzt hier die
mitte die äußeren stellen die fall dich
jetzt zusammen und auch hier in der
mitte falten ein bisschen zusammen
[Musik]
jetzt brauche ich nur noch ein bisschen
lebensmittels leber
[Musik]
er kann jetzt hier den teil nach innen
formen und auch auf dieser seite
und dann wird die schleife ein bisschen
dreidimensionaler aussieht lege ich hier
dazwischen etwas küchenrolle
[Musik]
und so las ich die schleife jetzt etwas
an trocknen und wetten jetzt schon mal
um dem mini maus ohren kümmern für die
mausohren habe ich schwarze modell
schokolade 3 mm dünn ausgerollt und sie
dann mit einem runden ausstecher 11 cm
groß ausgesprochen jetzt kann ich die
torte befüllen den teig habe ich ja
bereits gemacht ich habe auch schon eine
erdbeer frucht einlage gemacht die ist
schon im gefrierschrank da findet ihr
das rezept auch auf meinem blog und hier
habe ich jetzt eine französische
buttercreme vorbereitet und das wird
eine erdboden hier habe ich jetzt ein
paar erdbeeren das waren 600 gramm
tiefgefrorene erdbeeren die haben mich
eingekocht so dass wir fast keine
flüssigkeit mehr haben also richtig
jetzt werde ich einfach die eier masse
unter die butter heben und das etwa auch
unterheben
[Musik]
jetzt kann die tore befüllt werden jetzt
kann ich hier die zahlen zu schneiden
das heißt ja erzählt die große kuchen
platte und werde jetzt zwei streifen mit
jedem neuen cm breite zu schneiden
[Musik]
verliert der kuchen noch schön zusammen
ist nämlich jetzt die torten säge und
schneit in kuchen zweimal durch
[Musik]
nämlich einen teil buttercreme und
streichen jetzt auf mein kate bord das
setzt sich jetzt den ersten stapel drauf
[Musik]
der zweite teil hier das kommt jetzt
dirk werth runter aber natürlich nicht
die komplette breite das muss jetzt ein
bisschen kleiner schneiden so dass unten
die einzelnen kleinen fuß hat
[Musik]
und aus dem rest formell vorne noch die
spitze
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich die erdbeere buttercreme
die app bei frucht einlage die schneide
ich jetzt gleich zurecht und werdet sie
dort damit befüllen
[Musik]
die torte wird jetzt rundherum mit der
französischen buttercreme eingestrichen
und nach dem ersten einstreichen stelle
ich sie dann für etwa eine stunde kühl
damit die füllung schön fest werden kann
und ich dann weiter daran arbeiten kann
damit ich eine von der decke darüber
legen kann muss die torte noch komplett
mit der restlichen buttercreme und glatt
gestrichen werden
das quad dekoriere ich mit kleinen mini
mäusen dafür rolle ich jetzt die modelle
schokolade ganz schön aus und stech
jeweils drei kreise für eine mini maus
aus der mittlere kreis ist der kopf des
ein bisschen größer und die zwei ohren
die sind ein bisschen kleiner
die schleife forme ich dann aus
pinkfarbener modelle schokolade und
drücke sie in eine kleine silikonform
und da kommt auch am besten wieder raus
wenn ihr die vorher mit bäckern stärke
ein bisschen bewundert und zum schluss
werden dann noch die ohren angeklebt und
eben auch die schleifen mit essbarem
kleber
[Musik]
die schleife bekommt jetzt noch kleine
punkte dafür rolle ich jetzt buyten
passte ganz dünn aus auf becker stärke
und dann habe ich mit einer spritztour
mit 14 mm durchmesser
die punkte ausgestochen und mit kleber
angeklebt wenn wir die schleife richtig
hübsch wird werden die punkte für das
innenteil ein bisschen kleiner gemacht
die restliche blüten pasta habe ich
jetzt bisschen antrocknen lassen und
nehme jetzt lebensmittel farbstifte und
schreibe jetzt den namen von dem
geburtstagskind also in meinem fall ina
drauf und dafür nehme ich natürlich die
walt disney schriftart damit es schwarz
noch ein bisschen versteckt wird nämlich
noch ein bisschen metallic farbe und
traktiert dann mit dem pinsel drüber auf
jetzt ist die torte fertig glatt
gestrichen und sie war jetzt etwa eine
stunde im kühlschrank jetzt habe ich
hier eigentlich nur schwarzen von dann
bereits mit rollen aus und denke damit
die torte ein
[Musik]
davon dann wird es ganz vorsichtig
drüber gelegt und damit dem hinten glatt
gestrichen und ganz wichtig sind jetzt
einfach die kanten dem ist da wirklich
ganz vorsichtig glattstreichen und dann
von oben nach unten arbeiten
[Musik]
der schwarze bereich ist jetzt fertig
jetzt kommt rosa an die reihe
den von dann habe ich jetzt auch bereits
dünn ausgerollt und habe ihn vorher
einfach mit bisschen pink eingefärbt
jetzt schneide ich hier eine gerade
fläche weg sie darf auch gerne
gesprungen sein das von einfach minnie
maus gleich sein und den fondant lege
ich jetzt hier so ein bisschen schräg
drüber und zum ankleben nämlich einfach
ein bisschen back trends prägen
[Musik]
jetzt ist das skateboard noch an der
reihe das ist momentan noch ziemlich
nackt dafür nehme ich jetzt ein bisschen
weiß und rosa habe zwei streifen weiß um
39 in rosa und wer das ganze jetzt
marmorieren das heißt ich zwiebel das
immer so ein bisschen drumherum
legst wieder zusammen rolle es zusammen
und knete ist dann wieder ein bisschen
und zwar so dass einfach eine schöne
mariette optik entsteht
jetzt bestreitet das skateboard mit
etwas essbarem kleber und verteilt mit
dem pinsel und dann schneide ich mir
hier immer so kleine stücke zu und legt
diesen sondern so ein bisschen entfalten
drüber
[Musik]
das skateboard ist überzogen jetzt kann
ich mich noch mal um die restliche deko
kümmern
das namensschild habe ich jetzt mit
lebensmitteln metallic farbe in gold
angemalt
jetzt bekommt die torte den letzten
schliff ich habe jetzt hier noch ein
paar weiße punkte ausweiten holland
ausgestochen
die werde ich jetzt auf den rosa teils
leben und dann im prinzip einfach alle
elemente die ich hergestellt habe auf
die torte töten
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt also die fertige torte
aus und ich muss auch sagen sie gefällt
mir richtig gut gefällt sind ja auch
schön sauber gearbeitet nur eigentlich
vielleicht ein businessplan dieses nina
strich ein bisschen und stimmrecht ja
ich wollte zu besorgen einbringen so
bittel altrhein bringen
ok ja und ich würde sagen diese torte
hat das ce siegel verdient oder cisco
google macht es drauf fertig sieht hier
oder anderen sogar nicht so stark sein
fragte wie hast du das gemacht und zwar
habe ich von meiner lieben freundin er
ist sie hat in kitsch deluxe laden in
speyer und die hat mir den mal geschenkt
und das ist so ein stempel den kann man
wirklich für alles benutzen
und ja das war echt cool jetzt habe das
kommen macht mal einen stempel aus
modellierte co laden die torte kann ich
jetzt natürlich nicht anschneiden wenn
ich dran denke mache ich aber ein foto
auf der geburtstagsfeier dies nämlich
über machen
das heißt die torte wird jetzt im
kühlschrank gelagert für zwei tage es
ging einfach organisatorisch nicht
anders morgen kann ich nämlich nicht
backen von daher darf die da etwas holen
und dann bekommt sie lena übermorgen die
torte sie selber wird sich zwar nicht
daran erinnern aber vielleicht schaut
sie in ein paar jahren dieses video an
und seht dann dass die tante sally ihr
was gebacken hat dann freut dass ich bin
noch ganz gut zum thema von und trocken
im kühlschrank lagern ja das ist
übrigens auch offene frage ob ford in
den kühlschrank dürfen ja sie dürfen es
muss einfach der untergrund stimmen das
heißt die creme muss einfach von dann
tauglich sein damit davon dann sich
nicht aufweist
soviel dazu im schnitt gibt es nicht
mehr aber ich werde davon berichten auf
instagram und auf facebook
wahrscheinlich und falls sie die torte
nachmachen möchte dann schaut nochmal
aufs feld der freitag gibt's noch mal
das ganze rezept und wie gesagt wir für
euch gerne ein paar themen wünschen zur
entsprechenden zahl dazu und dann machen
wir diese fan reise zu zweit genau ich
denke dass die zahl 2 wird ella la vita
im oktober schon 2 ok und da machen wir
für eine torte
was denken uns da was lustig ist auch
die ladung zu ende wirbelwind mädchen
lastig gabriela ist nicht so das
typische mädchen also bis zum nächsten
mal aus wie kleine tollen ein erlass
sieht aus wie das tigermädchen von
troyes wie heißt diese holzart monster
ag oder von toy story 2 monster einem
unserer ag war mit dem zopf genau dieser
frechen der kleine teufel ja und so das
monster könnten auch die dinge walking
dead weil jedoch immer so wild ist und
dann sagst du einfach durchs bild
alles da
[Musik]